. We have a voicemail number and that number
is two one nine two.
David P. Here's something I've actually heard
from a bunch of people about mass swearing.
Listen to this.
Hey, David.
So everybody who works in my office takes
the coronaviruses, David, seriously when they're
outside the office.
And then once we get inside, they'll think
they're mad.
They're not worried about something or anything
like that.
And I'm the only one to keep my mouth on hand
sanitizer.
You know how bad you think that?
This false sense of safety has contributed
to the flames are spread hugely, and I've
heard from this from other people, I'm really
good with my mask.
It's mostly red states.
I'm pretty sure that in blue states, every
every place says you've got to have a mask
on at a place of work.
Indoors is a generalization, blue and red
states.
But I've heard from people who work in Arkansas,
for example, South Carolina, South Carolina
is another example that begrudgingly, you
know, outdoors, people will wear masks, they'll
wear them at the grocery store, etc. but but
then at their place of work, they take them
off.
And even if you work with only eight people
and each of those eight people is only interacting
at home with two others, you're still exposed
to dozens of people's contacts.
And I know of many people who have gotten
sick this way.
And again, most of the contagion is happening
within homes and at places of work, particularly
indoor places of work.
So I don't really get it.
To me, the outdoor is less of a priority.
I'm still doing it because I'm a team player.
But the indoor, particularly when you're at
work all day with people, when we know the
longer you're around people, the more likely
a contagion event is to take place.
I really don't get it at this point.
I'm sort of beyond trying to understand the
logic that folks are applying to when they
do and don't wear masks.
I'm sort of at a loss, but I've heard that
from many people.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the potential extradition
of Julian Assange.
We will talk about Jayakumar and other Chinese
billionaires.
Smeet after criticizing the Chinese government
and much, much more get instant access to
today's bonus show by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom.